Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Subsurface scattering means that a portion
of incoming light penetrates the surface of
a material. Our skin is a little known, but
nonetheless great example of that, but so
are plant leaves, marble, milk, or snails,
to have a wackier example.
Subsurface scattering looks unbelievably beautiful,
but at the same time, it is very expensive
to compute because we have to simulate up
to thousands and thousands of light scattering
events for every ray of light. And we have
to do this for millions of rays. It really
takes forever.
The lack of subsurface scattering is the reason
why we've seen so many lifeless, rubber-looking
human characters in video games and animated
movies for decades now.
This technique is a collaboration between
the Activision Blizzard game development company,
the University of Zaragoza in Spain, and the
Technical University of Vienna in Austria.
And, it can simulate this kind of subsurface
light transport in half a millisecond per image.
Let's stop for a minute and think about this.
Earlier, we talked about subsurface scattering
techniques that were really awesome, but still
took at least let's say four hours on a scene
before they became useful. This one is half
a millisecond per image. Almost nothing. In
one second, it can do this calculation two
thousand times.
Now, this has to be a completely different
approach than just simulating many millions
of rays of light, right? We can't take a four
hour long algorithm, do some magic and get
something like this.
The first key thought is that we can set up
some cool experiment where we play around
with light sources and big blocks of translucent
materials, and record how light bounces off
of these materials. Cool thing number one:
we only need to do it once per material. Number
two: the results can be stored in an image.
This is what we call a diffusion profile and
this is how it looks like.
So we have an image of the diffusion profile,
and one image of the material that we would
like to add subsurface scattering to.
This is a convolution-based technique, which
means that it enables us not to add these
two images together, but to mix them together
in a way that the optical properties of the
diffusion profiles are carried to the image.
If we add the optical properties of an apple
to a human face, it will look more like a
face that has been carved out of a giant apple.
A less asinine application is, of course,
if we mix it with the appropriate skin profile
image, then we'll get photorealistic looking
faces, as it is demonstrated quite aptly by
this animation. This apple to skin example,
by the way, you can actually try for yourself,
as the source code and an executable demo
is also freely available for everyone to experiment
with.
Convolutions have so many cool applications,
I don't even know where to start. In fact,
I think we should have an episode solely on
that. Can't wait, it's going to be a lot of fun!
These convolution computations are great,
but they are still too expensive for real-time
video games. What this work gives us, is a
set of techniques that are able to compute
this convolution not on these original images,
but much smaller, tiny-tiny strips which are
much cheaper, but the result of the computations
look barely distinguishable.
Another cool thing is that the quality of
the results is not only scientifically provable,
but this technique also opens up the possibility
of artistic manipulation. It is done in a
way that we can start out with a physically
plausible result and tailor it to our liking.
You can see some exaggerated examples of that.
The entire technique is so simple, a computer
program that executes it can fit on your business card.
It also seems to have appeared in Blender
recently. Also, a big hello and a shoutout
for the awesome people at Intel who recently
invited my humble self to chat a bit about
this technique. If you would like to hear
more about the details on how this algorithm
works, I have put some videos in the description
box.
The most important take home message
from this project, at least for me, is that
it is possible to conduct academic research
projects together with companies, and create
results that can make it to multi-million
dollar computer games, but also having proven
results that are useful for the scientific
community.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!